congrats on the movie i watched it
yesterday thoroughly enjoyed this one
you've worked with jackie chan before i
am a huge jackie chan fan i'm curious
do you have a favorite jackie chan movie
and a favorite jackie chan stunt
well the
my my favorite movie is drunken master i
think is probably the classic
um
which was a brilliant film at the time
and he was absolutely brilliant in it
and all his stuff and that is
mind-blowing
um and uh
there's another one i can't remember the
name of but
it was all in one shot and he did the
most incredible
stuff
you know the usual jackie chan stuff
sort of um
[Music]
you know with ladders and all
the way he works on tablecloths and you
name it whatever props at hand he
somehow how inventively kind of
uses those things
but at one point he has to kick a cell
phone off the floor and hit a guy right
between the there's no cuts with this
he told me they went to about 150 takes
on this this one shot to get it um
to get it perfect so and it's a
marvelous sequence so that's probably
the best piece of action i saw yeah he
is amazing um i i like the way that you
do action it's very realistic and
grounded and it's not a cgi mess um just
being blunt um can you sort of talk
about and i know you plan your action
very carefully can you sort of talk
about some of the things that you did
for this film some of the action the way
you crafted these sequences
well first of all you rely on um
you you rely on a very good stunt
arranger um
and
the fight say between maggie and um
michael
was all choreographed as four players
you see what i mean that was the whole
idea of that sequence um but you know
i'm a great believer in the action
letting the audience see the action you
know not just
the whole thing being cut every one and
a half seconds and
noises off and blurs and this thing you
don't see any geography at all i i'm not
as that
i don't like that i really don't i think
if you do the action you've got to see
the audience has to see the action
um cause and effect
and also
the the action should be based on
character that's the other thing i think
you have to base it on the character you
can't action for action's sake
um
is is to me can get very boring but it
has to be related to the characters
somehow
i completely agree i love the scene
between michael and maggie at the
restaurant it's such a fun bit of
dialogue and they're acting and the way
it's shot can you sort of talk about
putting together that scene
well yeah i mean look richard wenk wrote
a great there's some great dialogue he's
he's very good at that and it's got got
touches of
you know touches or carry grafts about
the whole thing
it's a sort of sense of mischief but
these two are very competitive and that
kind of
um
that dialogue is two people
kind of um sword fighting almost you
know what i mean that kind of
and and the
the the the dialogue sort of crackles
along between them you know and there's
a it creates this kind of chemistry
between them
um and the whole competitive uh
uh of a competitive attitude between
them both so uh
and that's just
you know in terms of rehearsing and um
uh
rehearsing and
shooting is you know that's what we
ended up with you've made a lot of
movies i'm curious which of your films
do you think changed the most
in the editing room as a result of
whatever reason
probably green lantern because
undoubtedly because it was a studio
picture
and they re-edited the beginning of it
and there were other things as well that
they buggered about with um so that's
probably the one i think that otherwise
i've
pretty much had a
just about all my movies in my cup i am
out of time i'm just going to say a
pleasure to talk with you uh congrats on
this movie i wish you nothing but the
best thanks very much indeed